[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're going to see
what happens if you put rocks
in a vacuum chamber,
and try and explain
the result that we get.
[Music]
Over the years,
we have had dozens,
if not hundreds of people
asking to see what would happen
if we put a rock,
in a vacuum chamber.
I'm pretty sure, I
already know the answer,
but because so many
of you have asked,
we are going to try it,
and then we're going
to discuss why we're seeing,
what we're seeing.
The idea here is about
as simple as it gets.
We'll take a few
different types of rock,
put them into
our vacuum chamber,
and suck out all the air.
I've got a few different
types of rock here.
This one, I just pulled
out of a planter box.
It's a pretty
standard looking rock.
It feels heavy.
It's hard.
I would just call that a rock.
This second rock is
a volcanic type of rock
that's called Scoria.
It's formed when lava comes up
out of the ground,
and hitting lower pressure
forms lots of bubbles,
and then cools off like that.
It's not quite as light
or air filled as pumice,
but it is similar.
These two rocks are varieties.
of what at least
claim to be pumice.
They're both
commercially available.
This black one is sold
at fabric stores,
and is designed for restoring
the proper texture on sweaters.
It's extremely lightweight,
and basically,
it feels just like a sponge,
except it's made of rock.
This second one is
a cleaning stone.
I just got this
at a department store.
It costs like
a dollar and fifty.
Again, this claims
to be natural stone
that's just been cut
into the shape.
I'm not sure if it's supposed
to be actual pumice,
or just something
a lot like pumice.
Pumice is another type
of volcanic rock
that forms about the same way,
as the magma comes up
out of the ground.
It's no longer pressurized,
and all of the dissolved gases
in it form bubbles in it,
then solidifies in that state.
Pumice is supposed to be a rock
that's so light and full of air
that it can actually
float on water,
and we'll probably do
a little bit of that in a minute
after we've done
our vacuum tests.
I don't want to vacuum them
while they're wet,
so we're just going to do
our vacuum test first,
and if they survive,
we'll try the water thing.
We're now going to take
each of these rocks,
and give them a chance
to experience being
in a vacuum chamber.
We're going to start
with our densest rock.
Just set that down in there,
and see what happens is
we pull all the air out.
[Music]
All right.
That didn't do anything.
In fact, it did so little
that I'm going to add
a visual aid just to show
that things are
getting vacuumed.
This is a ziplock bag,
and it's just sealed off.
We're just going to add just
a tiny bit of air into it so...
Now let's see
if the bag does anything,
while it's in the chamber
with the rock.
Just so we can see
if we're really
getting low pressure.
[Music]
Bag is already moving.
Bag can barely be held
in place by our vacuum chamber.
All right, so the bags expanded.
You can see the difference
in the vacuum.
You can see
what happens-- Oh wow,
and now, it's collapsing.
[Music]
The bag expanded a ton
as we sucked all the air
out of our jar.
The rock did not move at all.
Rock - 1, vacuum chamber - 0.
Let's move on
to our scoria rock.
This rock has a lot more air
in it than the last one.
So maybe it will be different?
[Music]
I think that's as low pressure
as we're gonna get.
And once again,
a whole lot of nothing
happening to this rock here.
That was air rushing from
the valve pushing on the rock,
not the change in pressure.
All right,
let's move on to our really
lightweight rocks.
This one is mixed up in density.
[Music]
Nothing with that stone.
We've got one more left to try.
[Music]
That's about as much vacuum is
we're going to pull.
[Music]
And really, no change at all.
I just want to do a little test.
You can't really feel
these different rocks,
but we've got a scale here.
We've got grams and grams.
This rock is 147,
and this rock,
which I would say is
approximately double the volume...
22.
So this rock weighs,
more than six times as
much as this pumice brick here,
and this pumice brick is
probably twice the volume.
Which means this is 12 or 13
times less dense than this rock.
This one has so much air in it.
We are going to do
a quick demonstration to see
if these two rocks
float on water.
[Music]
Seriously, this one is
like about the density
of styrofoam, I think.
Floats extremely well.
[Music]
Now that I've put
this in the water,
we're going to throw it back in
the vacuum chamber, and just see
if it pulls any water out.
[Music]
Not really much there either.
So the water that got
on this wasn't really pulled,
into the stone at all.
It was mostly just
on the holes
and the surface of the stone.
But why is it
that we can put a Ziploc bag
in with almost no air,
and it balloons up to fill
this whole container,
but the stones that have
so many little bubbles don't
really seem to do anything?
It has to do with
how a vacuum chamber works.
Normal air, the air
that surround us,
if we are at sea level,
that's approximately 14.7 psi,
which stands for pounds
per square inch.
That means that every square
inch on your skin,
your clothes,
everything around you has about
15 pounds of pressure on it.
That's like the size
of a large bowling ball
pressing down on it.
It doesn't feel like that
because that's always there.
That's what we've grown with,
and down to our very cells,
that's what's normal to us.
When we start pulling the air
out of the vacuum chamber,
it's no longer
pressing on things.
So inside the ziploc bag,
if we just open this bag,
put a little bit of air into it,
and then put that
into the vacuum chamber,
when we turn
the vacuum chamber on,
there's no longer 15 psi,
squishing down on this bag,
but there is still air inside,
and that air went
into the bag at 15 psi,
which means if we pull
a perfect vacuum,
all of that air
would begin to press out
with that same pressure.
That would be 15 psi of air
inside a ziploc bag,
and the ziploc bag can't really
take that much pressure.
It's got thin plastic walls.
Squashed down flat again.
Back to the almost,
entirely empty that it is,
but the thing is,
it's not perfectly empty.
There is a little bit
of air in this bag,
and we can sort of maybe
squish it all into one spot
or something like that,
and we could see
that that tiny tiny amount
of air is what's expanding
on the inside when
the vacuum chamber is turned on.
So, there you go.
That's how air
there was in this bag.
And that expanded to completely
fill our little vacuum chamber.
So if the bag has
a little bit of air in it,
and the stones have
why is it the bag inflates,
but the stones
don't really change?
They don't inflate.
They don't crack.
They don't even chip.
There's not dust
flying off of them.
All through the inside of this
rocker tiny little air bubbles,
and when you pull
the air up around them,
they do start
exerting a pressure.
And as I said,
15 psi is a good
amount of pressure.
Each one of these tiny little
bubbles is only one or two
millimeters in diameter,
and although 15 pounds
per square inch is quite a lot.
When you divide it up,
it stops being so big,
and I know I'm crossing
measurement systems here,
but one square inch
has approximately 645
square millimeters in it.
And when you divide the 15 psi
of the atmosphere by 645,
you end up with 0.02
pounds of pressure.
0.02 pounds of pressure
isn't enough to break
through the walls of this stone.
It is a soft stone.
I think I can even
just break it off
and crumble it in my fingers,
but it's still not soft enough
that that tiny tiny amount
of air can break
through the walls of it.
So can you break rocks
apart by using vacuum?
No, you cannot break rocks
apart by using a vacuum.
At least none of the rocks
that I have available to me.
There may be some kinds
of pumice that are so light
and so weak and so full of air
that you can pull them apart,
and that seems like it
would be pretty fun to do.
But I've never used
one of those rocks.
I've never seen one
as far as I know,
and I don't think I'm gonna be
able to get my hands on one.
But it's interesting to learn
about why some things react
and some things don't,
and that's also sort
of a thought experiment,
when you're wondering,
what would happen to something
if you put it
into a vacuum chamber.
Is the amount of air
that's inside it enough
that it's going to overcome
the pressure of whatever's
holding that air in place?
So it is good to try things out,
although knowing
how the vacuum chamber works,
and what makes the difference
between something
that does or does not expand
can give you at least a start
of an idea when you're wondering
what's going to happen.
Guys, that's not all,
we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video,
and you should go
check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should do watching next,
and if you aren't a subscriber yet,
just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way you'll
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.